what is your pregame ritual I repair and
and that's about it
but usually we keep like the same
routine which doesn't involve any
supernatural stuff but but like usually
we try not to very routine too much yeah
I like to sleep yeah after lunch I
prefer to have a rest before the game
with my mind clear I didn't have that
one songs that i refresh after every
event and that I will listen at least
once before going to the game and then
another tournament another song first I
have enough then I listen to something
that helps me happen then I go for the
game so that's my little issue I like to
brush my teeth
seems to be quite practical and yeah I
think dressing calms me down as well you
can for a while focus on choosing the
the short instead of choosing the first
move and that is relaxing I actually
have a shirt and which I always do well
but then when it comes when comes the
game let's say I feel most comfortable I
black against very strong opponent I
don't wear that shirt because I want to
keep the magic going
preparation and some rest
some walk maybe I'll maybe I'll go to
the gym probably definitely listen to
some music though and definitely take a
nap before the game since it's a much
later start okay I bet if something and
I write the first a game some words and
and I believe when I write this word
City it is hard for me I usually sleep
in late so I don't have much more time
than to eat try to eat twice look at my
preparation maybe go for a short walk
and that's it
I think everyone well everyone wants to
sleep wants to eat wants to prepare a
little bit here and you know the only
task is to combine it correctly assume
not oversleep not to overeat and not to
over prepare for sure